Islam According to Islamic law here are
10 things that are considered Haram in
the religion of Islam starting at number
10 we have mistreating your wife so
mistreating your spouse is one of the
biggest sins and it's considered Haram
in Islam now the prophet Muhammad he
taught people that they need to be very
friendly a big misconception because for
some reason when a lot of Americans hear
Islam they're like terrorists and
beating women that's early treating
women like that's that's right where
they go yeah the Taliban they are cruel
to women horrible to women and they're
they do it in the name of Islam but
they're really a political sect more so
than a religious they're not a real
religious group so I think I think
there's the extreme Christians like
there's extremes everywhere that's what
I'm thinking and I don't really know for
sure but I'm sure that people will
correct me but my understanding is that
they are just an extremist group and not
really you know from all the Muslims
that I'm talking the uh the rules they
don't align with them at all so all the
Muslims I've ever met their women very
well but I've been hanging out with
Taliban so Muslim women are they're
great like from all the interactions
I've had they're very nice and they're
very they're very to themselves which is
very yeah which is very good in a woman
you're supposed to revert to Islam if
you want to marry one of them of course
because they're very strict about like
the sex before marriage and all that
stuff even in America like that's not
that stuff doesn't really fly yeah
they're definitely like the highest
quality ones because they don't have any
other partners and the the most like
feminine loyal girls that you're gonna
get let's go
friendly and kind to their wives
according to Muslim belief Prophet
Muhammad even stated that you need to
try to make your spouse your best friend
in Hadith narrated by Alter nudi it says
the prophet said the best of you are
those who are the best to their wives
and I am the best of you to my wives do
they have arranged marriages in Islam to
my wives they have arranged marriages
right I don't know if it's an Islamic
thing or a cultural thing but yes there
are still arranged marriage did you know
anyone that that ever happened to the
world do you know anyone that ever had
an arranged marriage that's like an
insane thought no in America this it
happens here but it is not common and if
it is it's real you know quiet I feel
like a lot of those couples end up being
really happy though which is pretty
interesting you feel like that from what
I've seen no you don't think so I don't
know I mean I'm not gonna lie like your
judgment of people in my life is scarily
accurate so there's been friends that
I've had who I thought were really good
friends and I trusted them but you had a
weird feeling about them and at some
point down the the space-time Continuum
they did some [__] and I had to cut them
out yeah and you called it way before
that's just like I think but it's like a
parent's thing you can look at some like
business partners Friends girls all of
it family members have always been right
if they have a bad feeling you my
uncle's my dad it's weird and I'm sure
you guys have had the same thing where
if your parents don't like someone in
the moment you might disagree with them
but down the line they're right yeah you
realize that they were right yeah so if
you know this if you know this then
arranged marriages could potentially be
a good thing if you know the partner if
you if you meet the other person and you
know the person that your kid would be
looking for it would potentially be the
most compatible with do you see what I'm
saying right okay so that's one layer of
it that I totally see what you're saying
and I think that makes sense that
parents could hopefully choose well for
you but part of the reason why it might
work let's just make a case for it you
know just for the sake of conversation
yeah and arranged marriage so we have
all these fantasies that have come out
of popular culture probably only in the
last couple hundred years in literature
where everybody thinks that they're
gonna fall in love and they're going to
skip to through life you know holding
hands in a meadow with the person that
they're madly in love with and the
reality is is that it just doesn't
necessarily work that way and then it
word marriage is what they used to be
before they became romanticized was it
was a practical Arrangement where two
families of similar means financial
means put up a kid and they decided that
this would be a good joint effort for
the family they did this at every level
right up to royal families where
countries would build alliances by
giving a daughter or a son to the other
country absolutely and they were they
were for political reasons you're gonna
find me about it and sometimes you know
you got stuck with you know some real
ugly broad or you know a guy with bad
breath or it was whatever but what
happened is they went in with
expectations of I'm just going to live
this life together we're going to build
a life we're going to build a family and
if you got lucky love was a part of that
equation interesting I also don't
believe in soul mates like at all I
don't agree with you on that but I don't
necessarily think that you're gonna
everyone's gonna find their personal
mate either I think that if you make
yourself more of a higher value person
and more compatible um you're more
compatible with a larger group of people
that's what I think like right now where
I'm getting myself more into shape I'm
making money upgrading my social status
upgrading my network becoming more
charismatic well spoken I don't think
it's just a soul mate thing where I'm
born and there's magically a person out
there I think me building all these
attributes about myself makes me more
compatible with more women does that
make sense I don't know if it makes you
more compatible with more women but it
definitely makes you more compatible
with Whitman more women who are similar
but also more more high value women too
high value from families that are of uh
have the similar values that you have
and that's the most that's really really
really important values oh I could never
date or marry a liberal like that's not
even but an arranged marriage another
thing that happens is you come to the
table with shared values in an arranged
marriage you're going to be from the
same culture you're going to be the same
religion you're probably going to be
from the same country or region yeah so
you have you have a foundation together
before you you even get to know each
other and you know we're trying to force
diversity and I'm not saying that
diverse marriages don't work that would
be stupid of me of course some do but
really A Lot of Things Fall Apart
because of that diversity that
everybody's in love for the first few
years and then when it comes down to oh
we have children [__] do we baptize the
child or not do we you know are we
sending the kids a public school or or a
private school what values are we
teaching them yeah what are we teaching
this kid do we want them to be a city
kid or a country kid what are we doing
and the parents can't really agree
because all the butterflies have worn
off so an arranged marriage takes all
that [__] out of the way too that's
true watch your mouth by the way it's
Haram that's going to be rule number
seven let's just let me just say that
sentence over and you can edit it no you
can you can so whenever in Islam is
tattoos now there's a Hadith that says
this may Allah curse the woman who do
tattoos and those from whom tattoos are
done definitely a red flag and a girl
when I see she has tattoos definitely a
red flag especially if it's some dumb
stuff like if her dad died and her dad
was seen as a dove or her mom died her
mom was seen as a dove and then the day
her mom died a Dove came in the window
then maybe I'd be like okay that's a
that's a good reason to get a tattoo
maybe but if she's just like out with
her girls getting tattoos and [__]
stamps that's that's so unattractive you
don't even understand I get it no I do
those who pluck their eyebrows and those
who file their teeth for the purpose of
beautification and alter the creation of
Allah that's actually really funny I
mentioned that in my podcast with the
three Muslims about plucking your
eyebrows and that came out
scientifically proven hundreds of years
later like in modern times that that
kills brain cells when you do that and
it's bad for you yeah which is weird so
you're saying that but I guess I just
missed the beginning of that is that an
actual quote from the Quran where you
what was going on 1400 years ago that
people were filing their teeth that it
was a big enough problem that they had
to write it down mom people are cutting
off their penises to become women
nowadays you think filing your teeth is
any crazier yes I think it's crazy to
file your teeth down to points I know
they're people that do that I've seen
them on the internet I didn't know 1400
years ago people were doing this crazy
stuff oh my goodness we've had problems
for so long I think that when you feel
the need to file your teeth down and
like it said Don't Mess With The
Creation yeah that God made you that's
my understanding as a Christian and I
think this the same probably I don't
know that's got to be the devil as a
Christian that's the devil that's the
devil getting to you and having you talk
but getting between you and God yeah
that's what that is and so it's a sin
it's a sin for tattoos and Christianity
actually I truly don't know interesting
I truly don't know I can't answer that
question it sucks because some tattoos
look so cool but I don't think I would
ever get one to be honest I don't know
but a sin is is the devil getting to you
is what I'm saying yeah yeah personality
so that's only the devil would make you
file your teeth down and mess with your
body that God Made In His Image makes
sense I mean I I understand it and you
used to talk about getting a tattoo and
I used to just say to you wait till
you're 30. because I was hoping that by
the time you were 30 you had better
judgment well the other thing is like
that's on you literally forever like I
want to be 80 years old it's the one to
be 80 years old with great grandchildren
and I'm gonna have a or you're gonna
have seven thousands of dollars to get
it removed I'll be multi-gajillion it's
not just money it's time and pain for no
reason no I hear you I hear you I get
you sip your water typically that's
found in albuquari alibes number
5587. charging interest is at number
eight and the term Reba refers to
interest and this is something that is
completely Haram in Islam right actually
due to the fact that it makes poor
people even poorer so like if you owe
money and your charge interest in the
end you end up poor because you end up
spending more money than you w Islam for
that one for real yeah let's let's hear
the rest of it actually owed now in the
Hadith from Abdullah in hamzala this is
what it's recorded that the prophet
Muhammad had said the prophet said uh
Durham or Reba which a man receives
knowingly is worse than committing
adultery 36 times
that is like you're taking advantage of
somebody it's almost like stealing so we
have a good friend who advises Muslim
investors and they only they build funds
that are specifically they call it Halal
investing where all of the funds are
with companies that are you have values
that are um you know Halal I guess and
he had taught us about these rules in
investing and the companies have to
follow all these rules I didn't know
about the interest one yeah and it's
it's the way you charge people has to be
ethical and I like that a lot yeah it's
there's a lot of rolls around the money
it's it's really nice and they do they
actually do Christian based investing
also it is pretty incredible what the
like um similar rule would be I really
do I I didn't even know this was a thing
and I've always thought interest was
like extremely evil like with these big
ass credit card companies and they're
just keeping people in debt basically
for their entire lives over something so
minuscule or like the government what if
you don't pay a what is it a highway fee
a highway toll that 30 cents becomes a
hundred dollars yeah extortion extortive
fee that's that's absurd that is
absolutely absurd that's a that's a big
absurd one one of the other most absurd
ones is that if you haven't overdraft on
your checking account if you're broke
and you don't have money and you have
seven dollars in your checking account
and you use your debit card for a ten
dollar charge you have overdrafted and
now you have a thirty dollar fee so
you're broke you don't even have the
extra three bucks that's the thing oh my
God yeah they make billions and billions
of dollars in overdraft fees they should
be illegal just say it should just be no
your card doesn't work you don't have
enough money so I think that's happened
to me yeah people get all kinds of money
right you know like now how do you and
it's all from people who are who are
broke and struggling already oh it's
terrible it's extremely unethical what
little I know about the Halal investing
I actually want to talk to Ryan more
about it but like I feel like that's a
good place to put money because you're
getting you're not investing in
companies that are doing all this crazy
woke devilish garbage that's a good idea
pretty cool let me know in the comments
if you want us to do a podcast with him
about Halal investing that way we could
mix our Muslim audience and kind of get
into the finance stuff drop a comment
yeah they know they know word Finance or
maybe a sentence I don't care what you
say if you want to see it we'll check
the comments okay and you know debt
payments is what kills a lot of people
because if you owe twenty thousand
dollars with interest you probably owe
closer to twenty five thousand dollars
thirty thousand dollars in some cases
next time I gotta pay off a car loan or
something I'm gonna tell you I know in
Christianity There Are Rules uh from Old
Testament rules about don't don't get
into debt to begin with you know don't
they you just get forget what you can
afford live within your means yeah you
know ask you want more ask God for more
work work with what you have so it's
probably in there too I'm listening
somebody you're charging interest on
that that's around adultery and
fornication coming at number seven now
there's a passage in the Quran Surah 17
verses 32 that says it's so funny that
they're like ranked from Top 10. number
seven sleeping around and number six
with the 3.3 goals per game the Quran
Surah 17 versus 32 that says this and do
not approach unlawful sexual intercourse
indeed it is ever an immorality and is
evil as a way so of course having
relations outside of your marriage as
well as having intimate relations not
being married
drinking alcohol isn't we have a lot in
common Christians man it's crazy that
these were like I do gotta get closer to
God because like it's crazy that these
religious books truly are just honestly
like maps for happiness and purpose
because like anyone that slept with
around with girls knows that that that
[__] is so empty like it doesn't if if
the girl isn't like absolutely in love
with you it's just like it's so
pointless you're just like oh that was a
whole night for nothing like yeah it's
crazy to think about but I don't know
like and I get called weird for that
where I'm like I don't know like just
getting random girls isn't really that
fun and it's not fun for the girls the
girls will say it's fun right especially
the the woke uh as a dude positive girl
as a dude where I'm the one that wants
to get multiple partners more than women
want to have these young girls naturally
but if I'm the one saying that that is
still empty I couldn't even imagine
what's wrong with these girls to where
they're justifying that for them doing
it it's just a desperate attempt for
attention and physical contact daddy
issues
um or it's drunken bad decisions uh and
what what happens at the end of it is
the next day is either disgust and
regret oh my God I was so drunk why did
I do that or it's oh my god do you think
he'll call me you know or will I ever
see him again that so like either way a
woman is almost every single time it's
very rare that it turns into a
relationship that ends up being you know
a happy marriage that lasts forever
that's almost never happens yeah it's
either going to be regret and discussed
or longing for something more well it's
sad too because Society pushes these
women to be so promiscuous and not only
does it make them less happy it lowers
their value and in the future they're
not going to find as good of a guy and
find as much happiness when they're
ready to settle down because a truly
good guy doesn't want to settle with a
hope and they'll just never be satisfied
either because they're always going to
be feeling like what am I missing and
you know just so this is sad it's sad
it's traumatizing look at all the porn
stars that we've ever seen give
interviews when they escape the industry
as they're sad they're depressed they
regret it they hate that all that stuff
is out there about them they want to get
married and have kids and even if they
do get married and have kids they're
just forever dreading their children
actually growing up and seeing all that
stuff so there you go it's sad can't
make a wife out of a home that's Haram
drinking alcohol is another big Haram
thing in Islam and is found in the Quran
05 versus 90. there's a passage that
says this o you who have believed indeed
intoxicants gambling sacrifices on Stone
altars to other than Allah and dividing
arrows are but defilement from the work
of Satan so avoid it that you may also
be successful but this is the thing in
Christian that you know sobriety and
turning from all things that dull your
eye from being on God anything like that
is from the devil and should be avoided
but I I actually have to ask my pastor
about what this looks like in
Christianity because you know there's
the whole wedding scene at Cana when
Jesus they ran out of wine and Jesus
turned water to wine it was one of his
first public Miracles so like I don't
know what the how that all makes sense
together but I do know that we are
generally supposed to be more you know
sober of sober mind and the apostles
taught us that I mean it's all just like
I said it's more psyops it's all alcohol
is it's so during covid everything is
shut down you can't even go to a gym but
a liquor store and pornography studios
are are Necessities that need to stay
open how does that make any sense how
why why is it so exciting three Studios
were open yeah they didn't think they
were they were movie studios pornography
Studios all that stuff because it was
entertainment but why is this stuff so
accessible that's something that I sat
down and I analyzed I was like why is
this stuff that's so popular in culture
and everything so accessible but then
other stuff is is so hidden you know
it's like they want you drunk all the
time it's the same as your phone they
want you working from nine to five
draining your energy going home and
ripping beers don't don't they want your
senses dull because then the next day
you're tired your brain is is even
slower you're not going to want to go to
the gym or better yourself you're going
to work your job like a slave not saying
you're a slave if you work a job you're
gonna work a job like a slave because
your brain isn't fully turned on and
then the rest of the day you have no
energy and it's right back to it and
thousands of people live this life
whether it's weed alcohol some type of
substance people that's what they do in
their off time could you imagine what
the world would be like if all the
humans actually live to their potential
human potential is amazing physical
mental intellectual it's absurd I tell
you this it's the same thing with your
like there's so many distractions of
Consciousness even on your phone like I
said whenever for a lot of you guys are
probably in school so have you ever
noticed when you're like doing a
homework assignment or something and it
gets a little bit hard then you'll like
go to your phone open Instagram Snapchat
just for a couple dopamine hits it's
like why are you doing this if you just
shut that stuff off and just use your
brain and put it into Focus mode you
could solve this stuff so much easier
for me when I'm in business and I need
to like figure something out or I need
to write a video script it's always when
I'm like walking my dog without
headphones when I'm in the shower right
before I'm going to bed at night and a
lot of the times that happens to people
because they they find they're good
ideas at the same time when you're in
the shower walking alone or um going to
bed at night it's because that's the
only time you let your brain think the
rest of the time you're on drugs alcohol
or your phone is taking your
Consciousness I'm so glad you're saying
this because you know I'm just coming
off of being sick for two weeks and I
have spent went either just like laying
around being really sick and coughing
and stuff spent an inordinate amount of
time either on my phone or just watching
something on my computer and in the
devices because I didn't have the energy
to do anything else and I feel like that
takes your energy more though it takes
my energy more right and I'm really
feeling that now like I'm trying to like
wake my brain back up again it still
feels a little foggy I'm still a little
sick but like how do I get that faster
and the answer is leave this goddamn
thing excuse me leave this damn thing
home when I go somewhere leave it out
keep it in the kitchen when I go to bed
at night so if I you know when I wake up
in the morning it's not the first thing
I look at I'm gonna start doing that
today and it's crazy and it's like it's
like even if you need to look at
something on your phone that's useful
and let's say you needed to check
Instagram for a quick video for
something that'll teach you you're
sucked in oh it's totally sucked in or
you're looking for a tweet and before
you know it you're scrolling and you're
like what is going on right now I've
been getting so much hate on Twitter
today I must have checked it 100 times
it's insane number five slaughtering
animals the wrong way this is also Haram
so if a Muslim is slaughtering an animal
without saying Allah's name it'll be
considered Haram a person should say
Bismillah
also this is what the Quran has to say
in Surah 6 verses 120. when I was on
that podcast with the three Muslims we
watched a video of how they kill the
animals properly and it's like
surprisingly peaceful which sounds weird
to say but this giant animal they'll
flip it over and it totally and bits I
you know what can we skip this because
it makes me so sad last thing and then
we could skip it because I know you
don't want to talk about this it's a lot
more Humane than what the 99 of the meat
is no it's not it's not it's not the
killing part that bothers me it's the
way the way that they're forced to live
up well that's part of it too I'm pretty
sure it's like it could just be like
caged in yeah no it's really factory
farming and I I it is absolutely
horrendous how we treat our animals in
this in this country is all I can really
speak to we only eat grass-fed though
right um no that's not true you can't oh
it's not always available and it tastes
better that's another thing though it
tastes this is another like scientific
part of it where it's not only it tastes
different and it's better for you when
the animals don't have all that stress
inside of them
no guilt the thing took a bullet between
the eyes I didn't even know what was
going on I had zero guilt about eating
it I do occasionally have like big waves
of guilt about eating Supermarket meat
that I know I feel this animal had a sad
hard life for what I you know it bothers
me an animal you could have loved yeah
no it's it is yeah because you know of
animals and but I'm also I have a lot of
food allergies so if I don't eat them
I'm gonna die yeah I don't wanna I don't
want to keep going on about this because
I know it'll bother you but yeah let's
skip let's move on eat not all believers
of that meat on which Allah's name has
not been pronounced at the time of
slaughtering of the animal testament
which is a sin most of you even if
you're not Muslim probably knew this
already eating pork that is Haram even
if you use Allah's name during the
slaughtering of a pig eating pork is
still going to be you know what we
should survivors look at them they're
adorable they're smarter than dogs
they're friendly except for them aren't
they technically bad for you too or some
sign says that but who knows how true it
is that's the same people never ever
ever ever eat pork again that's pretty
interesting how they knew that 600 years
it was 20 years ago 1400 years ago I
mean 1400 years ago I should have known
that prohibited to you are dead animals
blood the Flesh of swine and that which
has been dedicated to other than Allah
and those animals killed by strangling
or by violent blow or buy a headlong
fall or buy the Goring of horns and
those from which a wild animal has eaten
accept what you are able to slaughter
before it's death and those which are
sacrifices don't alters and prohibited
is that you seek decision through
divining arrows that is grave
Disobedience this day those who believe
have despaired of defeating your
religion so fear them not but fear me
the day I have perfected for you your
religion and completed my favor upon you
and have approved for you Islam as
religion but whoever is forced by severe
hunger with no inclination to sin then
indeed Allah is forgiving and merciful
so yeah very long passage that included
the point that eating pork is Haram in
Islam and number three we have suicide
it's like just don't be an [__] to
the animals and and eat and kill it in
Allah's name in the Hadith specifically
bukhari janae's 84 it says he who
commits suicide by throttling Shout keep
on throttling himself in the Hell Fire
forever and he who commits suicide by
stabbing himself shall keep on stabbing
himself no that's not to see we don't
have that in Christianity if you're a
Believer it obviously we don't want
people killing themselves but it is not
an automatic ticket to hell it's
Purgatory no you if you get there if
you're a Believer and you're you're
going to Jesus and you repent of your
sins those are the two requirements you
believe that Jesus is who he says he is
and you repent of your sins and you're
sorry for your trespasses here on this
planet then you can get into heaven and
be forgiven and loved and have eternal
peace so that's interesting that's our
Jam it's different makes you think man
it really does make you think but I I
would like to know what the scholarly
understanding is and Islam behind it I
mean is it just that you're just
disrespecting Allah's creation by
killing yourself you're being like
you're disregarding the one most
beautiful thing he gave you which is
life I'm sure there's tons of reasons
behind it yeah I'd like to know I'm just
thinking about like The Eternity thing
like you're in Hell Fire stabbing
yourself for eternity but it's like if
if you're in the spirit sense what like
isn't time all just relative because
time is time is only the way you
perceive it you know what I mean we're
only I think it's different on the other
side no I I know but I was thinking
about that so I'm like for forever like
what the what does that even mean
imagine stabbing yourself for 30 seconds
if I was like just stab yourself as fast
as you can for 30 seconds that would
feel like eternity and then trying to
imagine eternity you know what I was
just thinking about too that's basically
like undeniable proof of God in my
opinion is the fact that we live in a
world that doesn't make sense objective
reality reality doesn't make sense you
know I'll say this right now what
happened first I don't know
some will say the big bang and then what
happened before that that's a theory but
then what happened before the Big Bang
right what happened before that you just
keep asking that and then it's like what
but it just keeps going or God answers
that so then where were we in this whole
thing we're just somewhere here how does
this make any sense we're in a world
where time the most important thing
doesn't even make any sense how this is
I'm so glad you're saying this because
this is why turning your life to God is
so very crucial because it has answers
for some of those things but and part of
that answer is you can't understand all
that because you're limited because we
we can't even fully see God in this life
because we can't handle it on on this
Earth and it also solves all the other
problems all the other uh you know
sharpening of the teeth and cutting off
of the genitals and all the things we
get upset and all these all these sins
that weren't supposed to avoid when we
see people out in the world living like
this and we live like that ourselves
even at times it takes all of that away
when you're you have your eye on guide
and you realize that none of this
matters that all that matters is those
bigger things that Infinity that
timelessness that Eternal peace and
eternal love pretty cool pretty cool but
I feel like that one question alone
solves a lot of it's like what happened
first number two a very big Haram thing
making statues and pictures especially
when it comes to prophets of Islam now
in the Hadith narrated by Abdullah Umar
this is what it says Allah's messenger
said those who make these images will be
punished on the day of resurrection and
it will be said to them make alive what
you have created and finally most
Muslims would agree on this is that sure
the only understanding I have or you
know what I've heard around that is
stuff from the media I guess I just
don't really understand what the big
deal is but if they say it is I get it
fine I I'll respect it totally that we
can't so there was a newspaper I believe
in France that created
um a cartoon images of Muhammad and
you're totally not allowed to do that
and uh
islamist extremists you know committed a
bunch of murders in retaliation for it
that's not cool and that those are the
things the way we have with any
extremists and any ideology or religion
you know really put a really bad light
and made it really hard for Muslims who
don't do that and and it and it bothers
me because that passage just said on the
day of Resurrection you'll be punished
that's when you should be punished you
know people here on Earth are using
these things to punish each other and
it's not it's people being crazy it's so
frustrating because if the thing is if
you still follow the book truly you
wouldn't do that so it's just people
taking it totally I'm not blaming I'm
not blaming the Quran um at all and I
want to be really clear about that but
it's another situation where you then
have you know this whole shadow cast on
this entire multi-billion person
population who is in tremendously large
heart innocent and and harmless yeah and
it's really sad and frustrating but I
I'm just sharing that because that's all
I know that's how I learned that from
popular it's incredible no it is really
interesting like my favorite people to
do business with are Muslims too like
just in personal experience there's only
been one who had a really bad experience
with and all the others have been
absolutely amazing what's number one
agree on this that shirk is the biggest
huram thing in the religion of Islam
shirk refers to associating partners
with Allah and this is the most serious
thing it's said that the prophet
Muhammad said these words shall I not
tell you of the most serious of the
major sins we said of course o messenger
of Allah he said associating anything in
worship with Allah also there's a verse
in the Quran Surah 4 verses 48 and this
is what it has to say indeed Allah does
not forgive association with him but he
forgives what is less than that for him
who he wills and he who Associates
others with Allah has certainly
fabricated a tremendous sense so like
let's say I called LeBron James God
that's what I'm thinking kind of like
idolatry how we're not allowed to
idolize anything but God that makes
perfect sense but I wonder if like it
makes you think like there's so many
weird things with dialogue and um which
is like which is language in general
where it's like we call it the elites
Elites because that immediately just
calling them Elites that puts us below
them with things like calling people God
like that's so common like you're like
this guy's a God that's so common but
it's like why is this all who who put
this here for us to be saying this so
frequently when it's obviously known and
these books which are important that
that's wrong that's the devil I know it
sounds so crazy because I we've never
even talked in these things no but it's
it's not it's not it's not crazy because
then it's these same people with the
most influence that are showing that
they worship the devil in real time like
Dojo cat is the she's making herself
it's clear that they idolize the devil
all of them little Nas twerking on the
devil she was just dressed as the devil
and then she made her profile pictures
all like some satanic possessed being
like they don't even hide who they're
idolizing all these celebrities and
they're the ones with the most influence
that dictate the way we speak in our
language yeah I think they're just
trying to be those people are just
trying to be edgy and attention grabbing
and is that what it is and then but they
don't realize that they are that is the
devil that's making them do that do you
know that right now as we speak this
weekend uh in Boston is Satan Khan It's
the first big satanic convention that
thousands of Satan worshipers are in
town gathered to pray and discuss their
religion and their religious rights and
all that a lot of trainees at that [__]
I don't know what goes on there I'm glad
I'm actually glad I'm not in in that
City right now I don't want to be where
that is
it's nice that we moved away I feel like
a lot of this crazy stuff it's nice that
I put myself in far away from a lot of
this crazy stuff yeah and I think that's
crazy [__] here in Florida but nothing
like nothing bunch of rednecks I like to
get messed up yeah so any kind of
idolatry is in Christianity the devil
coming between you and God and taking
your eyes off God and so this is what
I'm hearing here with shark it's you
know your eyes are on Allah and that's
it and that's that's where you live your
life how you guide your life the rules
you live by do not worship your spouse
do not worship your children your job
your money uh any number of things an
athlete possessions You Name It We gotta
keep on so in the religion of Islam only
Allah can be seen or viewed or worshiped
in the position of Allah nobody else or
nothing else can be compared and now you
know 10 things that are Haram in Islam
if you didn't know before very nice yeah
when you when you really start paying
attention to God it makes it really easy
to see the devil and and he did that the
devil is like in front of your face
sitting next to you in your own head in
some many so many instances it's true
right in front of our eyes it's
mind-blowing and I am just I'm a
Christian and I I of course part of my
job as prescribed for me in the Bible is
to just be be a disciple spread the word
spread the gospel bring people closer to
Jesus you know who are who are either
spiritually dead or or already have a
relationship with him but they need to
get closer but quite frankly I don't
feel like I'm in competition with Islam
if people are moving to Islam somebody
is being saved by Islam and and they're
they're going to be living by these
rules you know where there's of sober
mind they have their eyes on God they're
faithful and kind to their spouses
they're good to animals it's the same
God these are these are great I don't
these are this is wonderful like I I
don't I know I yes I have a preference
but I don't have any disdain for
somebody who's moving towards Islam if
they're truly living a better life and
getting away from the devil and getting
out of this world and have their eyes on
God and the next World this is cool
indubitably all right well thank you
guys so so much for watching I'm giving
a hundred dollars to someone who follows
me on Instagram at sunnyfaz follow my
mom at mothersunny whatever it is
talk about it on Twitter I love chatting
on Twitter go follow her on Twitter so
that she'll leave me alone and stop
busting a Feeling I should get off my
back off camera and I'll see you guys
later
[Music]